[Music]
welcome back to another awesome video of
the careful boys very very careful watch
it speaking about careful
what was
the scariest moment of y'all's lives
scariest moment scariest one of my
scariest was
sophomore year no
yeah sophomore in high school
and it was in the quest of the puss
and um my girlfriend at the time lived
i think three main
intersections away from where i live
so that's like
carmonada and south street if you're
familiar with
specifically
uh guitars or sam ash
and um
and so like the way we would meet up
would be in the middle of night i would
ride my bike
to her house and we'd kick it
and um so one of the nights i was just
riding
my bike over there and i parked it like
a street away
oh and also the funny thing is her older
brother was in the rival gang
so there was romeo and juliet that's why
that's a side story that's why we didn't
get it that's already really kicking in
and uh on campus i remember now so
that's how we can kick it on campus wow
that's passionate so i would [ __ ]
romeo and juliet a block away and then
uh this one night i just had like a
beanie on cause it was cold whatever and
then i would climb on the fence and then
she would open her window and i would go
inside oh wow and
for some reason i don't know like who
spotted me but i guess the neighbor
called the cops because they saw a
burglary happening
so while we were making out all of a
sudden your
in the front door and like um like
people would step aside we have like
reasonable doubt or whatever that your
husband burglarizer might be and you
just hear the mom scream like oh sheep
snakey whatever
like the mom was screaming and the dad
was screaming and then um
and then so they're like they came into
the door they're banging on her door to
like wake up wake up there could be a
robber in the house and then i was like
oh [ __ ] i don't know where else to go
because you can also see flashlights
coming in from where the window i came
into the house so the cops are already
securing the perimeter while going
through the house so i have no [ __ ]
where to go and my heart was going dude
i'm like [ __ ] with the [ __ ] do i hide i
[ __ ] open her closet [ __ ] there's so
many goddamn clothes in here
so what i end up doing is here's her
window and here's her bed
i laid like i i i stuff myself into the
corner like this
and uh i try to put like like the
blankets over or whatever and then her
mom finally opened the door she lets her
in and she goes are you okay and she's
like looking around and it's dark no one
turned the lights on and when she walked
over here to look out the window i could
see her through my face and i'm like
holy [ __ ] if you look down right now i'm
[ __ ] dead
you didn't cover your face no i did but
i have it like this so i can see it
but there's a nose print
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and
uh it was cool like she didn't see me
and then the cops left but my heart i
felt like it jumped out of my [ __ ]
chest that's pretty scary i was like oh
i was like that's out of a movie i was
going to get caught so many ways you
know like dope sex right after that yeah
yeah we even have sex we're so young and
then um
just have like this dry humping
yeah it was like her parents would have
caught probably would have whipped my
ass her brother who's older
probably would have whipped my ass the
the cosplay i would have what my husband
took me home and it kept my ass up over
there again yeah
[ __ ] ass whooping tour yeah
that was pretty good that was a good
story wow
i was nervous the whole time too while
you're telling me i love that
i gotta see what's going on
what's up with all these [ __ ] church
dresses
i think the scariest moment for me was
so when i was younger i must have been
like
eight seven or eight um when i was
living in arizona we were living in
north phoenix and my mom had a stalker
so like he followed her
a couple a couple houses that we lived
at so at the point like you know he was
like you know taking pictures of her and
all this type of stuff and you know she
called the cops on him had a restraining
order on him all that type of stuff so
we moved to north phoenix and she was
single because my parents have been
deforest since i was like two or
whatever is your mom pretty fine
yeah
[Laughter]
especially when she was younger i mean i
mean yeah a lot of a lot of guys like
you know
she was she's super pretty so ain't
nobody stalking my mom yeah and she's
still young my mom's only 50 years old
so i mean she was she was young when she
had us and
so you know we had she lived by herself
um it was just uh me and my two brothers
so we had like a huge alarm system on
our house and all that type of stuff but
i just remember one night
waking up like super fast and just
hearing the alarms like blaring
yeah i remember i still remember
bringing back because trauma yeah and
i'm like oh my god please don't do that
we had two
two bunk beds and i was on the bottom so
like i got up real quick and i opened my
door and had seen my mom's door already
open and i seen her like kind of
standing like like kind of like shook
and like walked out because we had the
walkway and then the stairs led down and
i walked out and i looked down and there
was a guy standing there and he like
looked at me and then just sprinted out
of the front door and i was just like
and then my mom screamed get in your
room and she ran
grabbed me we ran into the room she
slammed the door locked the door called
the police
and uh was that the stalker or was that
yeah so they say
they never like really caught them but
they believed that it was the stalker
guy so like
did somebody actually steal stuff or no
no he it was i it all happened pretty
quick i think the alarm scared him
but when i went out there the fool was
just standing right in the middle and
then
that means that means if his intention
was a robbery his intention was yeah so
oh man that [ __ ] was scary so like
growing up like any time i woke up just
like to go to the bathroom or something
like that i would always walk out and be
like [ __ ] hopefully no one's in this
[ __ ] house
did um your mom ever tell you how she
got a stalker like how this happened no
but
my my mom like her mom was also single
too and like my grandma would date like
you know she did from the stories i hear
didn't date the best guys so they kind
of got involved with like
a lot of bad people like there was 1.2
where she had another stalker so they
had some people i think it was from
either chicago or here when they grew up
out here
um you know my mom had stuff happen to
her from one of these guys so she let
people know and they got in trouble
uh but then when they got out they were
threatening to kill her so they were
like trying to chase my mom and stuff
like that so that's why they moved
around a lot so they moved to arizona
those guys followed them they got caught
in arizona and they got arrested sent
back to jail back i think that's a lot
of motivation to move off a whole ass
[ __ ] city just for one person yeah so
damn would it be insensitive to be like
we need to see a photo of your younger
mom so we can understand their mind i
mean i can show you guys my mom was
asking for a friend
joe
i'm asking for myself
how
because this this happens to celebrities
this happens to only fans girls or just
whatever like even youtube girls right
like like
they're they get so obsessed
with them that they'll follow them
throughout every [ __ ] city they'll
burn so much money just to be like in
their presence that's crazy yeah that
[ __ ] was like even like when i talk
about i start shaking a little bit
because i was [ __ ] like terrified i
remember it like just
growing up i was just like [ __ ] just
trying to go to the bathroom or
something i remember we had this toy
chest and like it's like a joke now we
make a joke about it but in that same
house we had a toy chest in the
in their closet i was so scared to go
pee in the bathroom i would just pee in
the toy chest
just going back that's traumatizing bro
hey dude come on
you didn't grow up with a dad
no i did but they were always separated
so my dad i mean like in the house oh no
that plays a big role if you have a man
in the house you feel a little more
protective the time my mom was single so
yeah it was just her
and then our three brothers we all had
rooms upstairs but yeah that [ __ ] was
crazy that was probably the scariest
moment my whole entire life because
that's [ __ ] crazy does it affect you
till this day like when you is it still
a little hint like if it's weird because
like when i talk about i still shake a
little bit because like it was
so scary
uh not really though like nowadays i'm
i'll [ __ ] someone up like if they're in
my house so it's like you know i got
trained by nick nicholas ear so you're
gonna get beat up right
or you get knocked out
help that dude to death but uh no like
it did for a while i think once i
started getting a little older and i was
just like more confident just like oh
someone walked in here and then like
obviously growing up my dad at my dad's
house my mom's house we started having
when she got remarried there was like
like more guys in the house and me and
my brothers were older so it's just like
you know we could defend ourselves but
at that point i was like i think i was
seven or eight my brother michael was
nine and my older brother was 11. so
it's like if we were going to try to
fight a grown-ass man it wouldn't have
went well for us three ninjas dude
let's go this is so good
give me that that is a crazy [ __ ]
story yeah speaking of ninjas so were
there ninja turtles in the toy chest
we were huge fans i was a huge
michelangelo fan mother brother was
raphael turned them into [ __ ]
pionardo dude
i always we always bring that up because
i yeah i used to straight up just pee in
our toy chest can i ask you more
questions about the toy chest yeah i'm
fascinated by it it was a big black one
that had like this cool like
like beige lining around it but it had
like a huge lock on the front but it was
like leather
how often would you pee in like this hey
guys today's video is brought to you by
kerology
so curology is pretty freaking awesome
because they made skin care not only
easy but super duper accessible for me
all of my male years of living on this
earth i was never introduced to skin
care
and and you know it's not something that
guys did just growing up right and even
if i went to like the pharmacy or
whatever and i checked out all the
different things that was there to wash
my face put lotion on or whatever i
didn't even know where to start i mean i
didn't even know what i needed and it
was just so intimidating i was like you
know what i'm gonna use bar soap or just
rinse my face
one of the sickest things about them is
you go online and you can fill out a
quiz right and you can tell them what
your goals are like let's say you got
acne you got clogged pores dark spots
fine lines whatever you take this quiz
and if you're good fit they give you a
custom a licensed dermatology provider
gives you a custom kit to help you
achieve your goals and this is what it
looks like or at least for my kit this
is what comes in i've been you know
using their products for like the last
two years now and what i have is this
moisturizer to keep my face moisturized
and if you live in dry climates like
california or las vegas and nevada it's
very nice i have a custom i took out the
survey and it even has my name on it
jojitsukawa right here and it has a
formula of my needs i don't want to be a
grandpa face okay i got
oily skin and dry skin and i don't want
any of the wrinkles so they got me this
and i have a face wash so they made it
super easy for me and they ship it
straight to my door and it makes it as
easy as a one two three you know so if
you want to check it out go to
curology.com
off the record because i got a super
cool deal for only five bucks for the
shipping and handling you get a free
30-day trial so you get to try it out
for a whole month for 30 days all you
got to go to is cureology.com which is
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash off the
record to get a free 30-day trial all
you have to do is pay five bucks for the
shipping and handling and you can cancel
at any time and your prescription is
subject to the consultation check it out
oh until until that toy chest was gone
did you clean it out yeah yeah so wow
so what did it smell like did your mom
ever like confront you about this no did
she didn't know until i was like 25. oh
really
it didn't just i mean things don't smell
like piss though yeah
you just kept under wraps huh i just
kept it underneath that's what i'm more
impressed with like that's pretty crazy
i mean you don't have the decency to
dump that [ __ ] out in the morning you
just let it [ __ ] evaporate into your
toys at school the next morning
that's cool what if you wanted to play
with pionardo you just dealt with the
piss stain on it yeah i think it would
dry up by then so i just didn't even say
oh it is arizona yeah but i just dried
up by the way rise up before it hits the
chest as a kid i didn't want to tell
everybody like oh i'm so scared to go to
the bathroom and yeah so i was just like
you realize as you're older yeah did you
ever get a gun or guns when you got
older my mom hated guns so she never had
them
she still to this day hates him she
might reconsider that my dad has guns so
well every time we're at his house which
was also another scary thing because
like our room like we had my two
brothers we all shared a room and it was
downstairs right right by the front door
and there's this huge ass window
so and like you know at the time when we
were younger the neighborhood was bad
like we had just had this kid killed in
a little like well down right by our
house and it's a bunch of [ __ ] i think i
might have told you guys a story or
something but like i went outside and
they were chasing somebody and the
helicopter shining the light on me so i
just like froze and it was on there and
then all their income get back in your
house and i was like oh [ __ ] i ran back
into the house but
so that was also scary too but my dad
did have guns so that was always kind of
like a little all right at least if
someone breaks in here at least you know
he's gonna pop off and then we all also
my dad had big dogs my mom always got
boston terriers which i mean
you just picked that one dogs would do
it yeah
yeah but no that was that was that was
definitely scary and it affected me for
a while yeah but then yeah got older
started using toilets or using toilets
but it was crazy i was so terrified
because like i still remember it clear
as day like when you'd walk out of the
room the bathroom was like right where
you guys are at but i was too scared to
because i didn't want to walk out and
like say there's like a guy waiting or
something [ __ ] like that it's real bro
it's scary no one even robbed me as a
kid but i remember in second or third
grade i was just scared of the dark
and my grandpa would always buy me like
these chinese kung fu swords when i was
a kid hell yeah and so i would like when
i had to pee i would take it out into
the bathroom and just like stick it in
the empty bathroom it's like this who's
in there who's in there and then i would
like turn on the light what if you turn
on your light and your mom's all cut up
when i would shower i would always
shower
like this way where like i would always
be able to see the outside so i would
never like wash my hair to where the
water would go over my face
because i was like i need to make sure i
can see if something like but i think
that was from like scary movie [ __ ] or
something yeah i'm saying yeah because i
was afraid of ghosts man but you were
afraid of an actual real human being
being in your house my mom lived in a
haunted apartment so she told us these
stories when we were kids so we were
[ __ ] terrified you lived in paranoia
all your life she told us this was so
much more sensible so they had to bring
like someone into the house right to
like unhaunt it or whatever oh you
should bless it bro yeah
but so you know there's just the normal
stories they said they claim when
they're all sitting watching tv their
ashtray started spinning god and then
all of a sudden normal stories
yeah i feel like it's a normal ghost
it's a normal ghost [ __ ] but then also
like she said at random times it would
just get pitch cold and then just warm
again and they would just like hit and
then go away hit and go away energy bro
and then she used to sleep in a room and
her cat always slept in a room and they
just randomly the cow would just
and then chase something out of her room
and like every once in a while she said
she would feel this
like on her chest and the cat was over
here and
and so like that was just normal ghost
stories but the crazy one that got us
scared as kids
was that she told us when the people
came in to like ask you know to cleanse
the house or whatever my mom had this
story she said i went down into the
basement and right when i got to the
last step it felt like someone pushed me
off
and she said it felt weird so she went
and grabbed her stuff and she said it
felt like someone kept like touching her
and poking her so she went up she's like
i literally told not a single soul about
that she's like so when the guy was
there and he was talking to like the
people that were haunting the house she
goes to my home he's like oh so uh about
the basement
and she's like what do you mean she's
like yeah the little boy told me like he
was trying to play with you so he pushed
you off the last
oh [ __ ]
so we were [ __ ] terrified i was
getting like what the [ __ ] and then my
mom's telling she's like yeah i woke up
one night and i swear because we got our
house built in levine and it used to
just be like pitch dark there was no
like street lights or anything like that
so you could see all the stars which was
pretty cool and [ __ ] but she's like i
woke up one night and there was a guy
standing but it looked like he had just
had this huge hat but all it was was a
shadow or like it's our new house and
you're trying to like scare the [ __ ]
maybe it was pharrell
all of a sudden that song started
playing everybody was happy and [ __ ]
damn that one scared us the most because
we're like she's like i swear on my life
i told no one about the basement but
this guy knew exactly what happened in
the basement that was like [ __ ]
spirits bro that's crazy
so alex had all the scary stories
yeah dude i'm not getting chills over
here like you're like this is normal i'm
like [ __ ]
scary life fine mom it wasn't yeah
that's the trade-off that's the straight
up you get dude dang man
i had one that was like
pretty scary at the time but looking
back it was just like more like
severe bullying and i was like um i had
a fallout with with some people that i
was hanging out with
and then
they wanted to like
be friends again right but i didn't know
they were plotting against me
to basically get revenge
so i forgot what we fell out about but i
was like in sixth grade and then these
guys were like
freshman in high school
yeah it's baby [ __ ] right but that's
when we started smoking weed and tagging
and doing all kinds of stuff already
and then um
i remember like they came over like and
we hung out they're like hey we should
uh just have a sleepover and then just
hang out and i was like at this point i
was like oh we squashed it we're friends
again let's do it right
and then so like i go over with my
backpack full of clothes and [ __ ] and i
think like we're just gonna
i don't know smoke weed and hang out
so we get high
and then
he pulls out like a knife that he stole
from my uh fishing tackle box it was it
was like this buck knife it was really
nice my dad bought it for me for my
birthday and he's like damn look at what
i found it looks just like yours huh and
then they grabbed me and they stuck it
to my neck yeah
and then they're like we could [ __ ]
kill you right now you know and i was
all like
[ __ ] like i was like don't kill me and i
i i don't know like at that point i'm
like what sixth grade right was that 12
or something eleven right i really
they're laughing like they're probably
just like bullying me but in my head i'm
like these [ __ ] are gonna assassinate
me right you think you're gonna oh yeah
high off my [ __ ] brains bro so i
can't believe what's happening so i'm
just high as [ __ ] and then like it's
killing my high i'm like like sobering
up first off that's why he's mad he's
like killing my heart
bro this is [ __ ] up he's sticking to
my deck and they're like you want this
[ __ ] back and i'm all like yeah man it's
a [ __ ] gift from my dad what the [ __ ]
you stole from me and then
they're like all right cool throw these
on and then they put on uh they threw
boxing gloves at me and they're like
you're gonna fight every single one of
us and i'm like you guys are [ __ ]
ninth graders and [ __ ] tenth graders and
i'm i'm a sixth grader so i was like
[ __ ] it bro and then like i just fought
every single one of them afterwards um
one of the the dad came home and he came
with the little brother and then they
saw that we were boxing in the backyard
and they saw i had like tears in my eyes
and [ __ ] and he's like what are you guys
[ __ ] doing right and then he he knew
we were all high whatever but you know
me i'm like i ain't no [ __ ] rat right
so i'm like we're just playing you know
that that [ __ ] goes down like they [ __ ]
with you and then like when the adult
comes everyone's like scared and [ __ ]
and you're like oh no we're cool and he
knew like he came up to me he's all like
hey are you okay like
you know uh is everything are you okay
and then i'm like i'm not gonna [ __ ]
right no [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm just high
eyes all red i'm like what the [ __ ] i
can't even think and i'm like no no no
it's cool it's cool it's cool whatever
right
and then he's like all right well okay
you guys have fun and then he goes in
the house right and i'm like [ __ ] i
needed to be rescued
like you know they got bored or was just
like we're not gonna fight anymore
whatever right and then like um they had
the bright idea to go to a [ __ ]
abandoned house right so they're like
let's let's go uh [ __ ] ghosan or
whatever yeah it's cool now right so we
hopped the fence to a back alley we went
to this house that that was abandoned
and they were just fixing and then like
i know [ __ ] idiot right i was like i
know what you guys are gonna do you guys
are gonna hide in the corner try to [ __ ]
with me and scare me
and then like no we're not doing that
we're just trying to look for things and
then like when i was there i heard them
they're like how do you know how do you
know how do you know and i was like man
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so like i was like hella
blocks away from my house but i just
like went to the corner and i just
hopped the fence and i just booked it
all the way home and then like i left my
backpack everything i just knocked on my
door and then my parents opened up the
door and then in my mind all i could
think about is like man my cousin knows
gangs and like we could kill them like
we're gonna [ __ ] kill them and then
so like all i could think of obsessively
was the revenge and how i'm gonna get
these [ __ ] back and after that they
jumped me a couple times because they
caught me slipping alone but that was
like years of paranoia of like they're
gonna catch me on the streets and they
caught me a couple times i [ __ ]
fought but like i didn't have backup and
i'm like oh [ __ ] no wonder i wanted to
join a gang because it's like if i
joined the gang then i have a way to
retaliate and kill these [ __ ] yeah so
i'm like man but
that was like um a pretty scary moment
because you just never knew when they're
gonna catch you yeah yeah yeah yeah damn
what a bunch of lame ninth graders huh i
know with a sixth grader sixth grade
losers dude
that's a pretty [ __ ] story man
do you know their names full names
where
i'll go box them
[Music]